tigers send jose or you you're right
urania
the amount of knight two and four
slider hasn't got good results his last
two starts
opponents five for eleven he gets him
first seven starts he got 30 outs only
six in his last two
probably won't see a lot of strikeouts
tonight and cesar hernandez greets him
with a fly ball to center on the very
first pitch of the night and a four
pitch walk puts jose ramirez aboard two
down here sadie rosario there goes the
runner the throw from rogers on a hop
and they got him
nice pick by goodrem he applies the tag
rogers got rid of it in a hurry
and you can look at the numbers over
there i'm not going to talk about that
i'm gonna talk about last october august
22nd when he made his major league debut
in progressive field against the tigers
he went six innings he allowed two hits
and only one earned run he punched out
ten he had a good fastball good
curveball and and change up to go with
it i want to see him do that tonight
it's this start and then back to triple
a terry francona has said as much the
pitch
a swing and another ground ball headed
to the second baseman in shallow right
hernandez throws him out
the pitch
and it's swung on skyball
into medium deep right center
and it'll be more straightaway center
than right center and it's caught by
jordan luclo so
again we've seen this a lot from trista
mckinsey two down bases empty no score
in the second tonight josh naylor is dh
14th in the league and there's a liner
to right that'll get down and josh
naylor gonna turn and go for two now he
jams on the brakes
and that's the time he should have tried
two outs gives owen miller a chance to
bat here the 2-1
to the left center field gap akil badu
cuts it off
quickly gets it in they're going to wave
naylor home
the throw is there and they got it at
the plate
to good room to rogers
beautifully executed and the tigers
defense saves a run
hernandez at the plate no score we're in
the third hernandez swings and pops it
up
on the left field line long run for
robbie grossman and he will reach and
make the catch what a play in foul
territory tagging and heading to second
is jake bowers and he'll make it
what a great play by robbie grossman he
made the catch and he was running out of
room right by the stands in foul
territory deep down the left field line
two on two outs now for jose ramirez
this will be the ninth pitch of the
at-bat here it comes
and it's lifted to right
no no mar mazara camps under it
and it's rorania who wins that
one-on-one battle
series following that
he was the hottest thing going
fastball wrong him up first k for
mckenzie two down in the third inning no
score for jake rogers the catcher here's
the windup here's the one-two pitch to
rogers and it swung on a mist he struck
him out with a slider
so mckenzie strengths out the side and
this kid looks like the kid we saw last
year
naylor with that single his first time
up then tried to score all the way from
first 2-2 fly ball center field deep
going back badou tracking it he will
turn and make the catch as he back out
onto the warning track in straightaway
center another good swing for josh
naylor
no
mckinsey wanted the fastball good for
him
look at that eight beautiful i love that
four straight strikeouts
for mckenzie you see what he did he did
that to mazzara when he was there and he
had him down in the count 1-2
batter
harold castro's it's so much easier to
pitch to these guys when you get ahead
of them
five consecutive strikeouts for stixx
mckenzie
i don't think it's a stretch to say that
mckenzie is razor sharp tonight
take what they're giving you
trying to keep that here either that or
hang it
the 01 slammed up the middle for a base
hit
there we go
first hit of the night for the tigers
the tigers have two on for the first
time tonight third walk issued by
tristan mckenzie has struck out five
nice weak pop up
left field eddie there you go two down
for jake rogers
high fly ball
field eddie rosario once again
five shutout innings for dr stixx
luplow's been hit by a pitch and hit a
fly ball to right the 3-2
all short slider for a strike middle of
the plate frozen
terrific pitch jimmy what was he looking
for there i mean really slider
apparently
he's pointing to his right forearm
aj hinch doesn't even hesitate no
no
so irania
his night is over
but a good one
deserves the applause that he gets from
the tigers faithful here at comerica
park tristan mckenzie went five innings
gave up just one hit walk three struck
out five only 73 pitches but they uh
they'll turn it over to cal cuatro now
swing and a miss at a good high fast
ball
one down
and that'll bring up harold castro
[Music]
miss oh i thought he got a piece of it
struck him out two away
here's jamer candelario in the scoreless
sixth inning
swing and a miss got him with a slider
up in the zone
that hit luplow
he says it did that's the second time
he's been hit by a pitch tonight they're
gonna say check it didn't hit him at the
last second i don't think it hit him at
all
[Music]
come on back
3-1 fastball above the strike zone at 99
and after all that after all that he
draws a walk no score we're in the
eighth inning
he sits him down
90 mile an hour slider
say goodnight to jose ramirez
four homers on the season for goodram
three of them
from the left side the two one
drives one to left center
that's down
cut off by the center fielder luplow
good room digging for second he's got a
lead-off double here in the eighth and
the tigers got something cooking
nana third for the first time tonight
for the tigers we're scoreless in the
bottom of the eighth inning and who
would you rather have at the plate than
this guy robbie grossman
he's the man oh for three tonight
cleveland infield is in
swing it away
fly ball center field should get the job
done
good room tags
no problem tigers lead at one nothing
not the way you want to start the night
here's harold ramirez oh for three
tying run at first nobody out in the
ninth one nothing detroit the o2
see you
he didn't like that slider did he well
one down in the tying run at first josh
naylor the batter
the 2-2
on a line could be a double play and it
is that's the way it ends rosario double
the first soto closes it out the tigers
break their four-game losing streak